what have we done in the past
and what we're doing now we learned to
dream big had a chance to talk to joy
just a little bit ago and she's talking
about his business she's about to build
she moves to a different part
of the country talked to kim a little
bit a little bit ago and she asked her
what what
what got into moving toward this
direction she said our kids have no hope
that's going to change our greatest
legacy
is giving our children the opportunity
to dream big
to hope across the regardless of the
obstacle
and to know this is a country truly of
second chances
of dreaming as big as one might want to
and we move forward with that
i'm so thankful president who's showing
us what it looks like
and for opportunity for those of us to
know what it is to replicate
a american loving leader
and we're going to do that done listen
guys i'm proud of you
you're the pioneers you're the ones that
can be leading our
our nation our race from the abyss of
darkness
thank you for your courage thank you for
your boldness thank you
for having the courage to stand up for
president who's standing up for all
americans
you guys are getting done i'm just i'm
just proud to be part of it thank you so
much for the opportunity okay
all the best
hello my name is kim klasik i speak soft
but i carry a big stick
when i decided to run for office i was
asked what makes you qualified
and then i turned around and i asked
that reporter what makes me unqualified
i get talked about a lot i read the
comments
on social media i get it i dropped out
of college
but you know what i work hard i had no
idea
walking down the streets in baltimore
would be a viral campaign ad
i had no idea that just caring about the
black community
would make me a target by the black
community on the left
but it's okay because i know with
president trump
i can bring so much to baltimore city
he talks about opportunity zones we need
that
he talks about school choice we need
that too we have 13 schools out of 39
where kids graduate not proficient in
math
for the past eight years i've been
working with my non-profit workforce
development
we've helped over 200 women become
gainfully employed
30 percent went on to be financially
independent
the only way you lift anyone out of
poverty is with employment
and i understand that and i know
everybody else does too
but we have to make sure other people
understand that and i and i hope
that people will vote based on their
best interest
this time around as we saw
during the coronavirus lockdown we had
to rely on other countries for ppe
we're supposed to be the best country in
the world
all of our manufacturing jobs went
overseas thanks to nafta and bill
clinton
but i know president trump will work to
bring that biotech industry
right back to america
[Applause]
after i'm elected that's right
after i'm elected i hope to work with
president trump to bring that billion
dollar medical equipment industry
right back through baltimore city's port
we'll have apprenticeship programs
career and job training
and i will make sure no one is displaced
in the city of baltimore
we have a big job to do and i know
everybody on this stage can do it
and i thank everyone for your support it
means a lot to me
thank you
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen
[Applause]
thank you thank you very much for that
very warm welcome
you know the very first time i met uh
donald trump
was at mar-a-lago in 2013 neither one of
us was in politics at that
time and he was so nice
he was so gracious he was looking after
me and my family making sure that we
were getting everything we needed
and rod stewart walked in and they said
mr trump rod stewart's here he said i
don't care
ben carson's here
[Laughter]
and our relationship developed during
the campaign so
you know when i dropped out
i had to decide who i was going to
support and during the campaign i came
to realize that he and i
represented the same things we we felt
very much the same
policy-wise we're a little different
personality-wise
but i i wanted to talk to him and see
how he felt about the issue that was
really the only thing that would have
encouraged me to go into government and
that was
what are we going to do about the poor
and the disadvantaged people
in our society and
i was really taken aback by
how much we agreed about what should be
done
to get rid of the paternalistic
attitudes
pat people in the head and say they're
there you poor little thing i'm gonna
take care of you
and instead partnering with people to
allow them to get
out of desperate situations that's
exactly what's happened
over the course of this time and
you know certainly that's what happened
in in my case you know growing up in
desperate poverty with all kinds of
crime around me
but you know i had something that a lot
of people
don't have an unfearing mother
who was wise and who wouldn't
allow us to be victims and made me read
books
i didn't want to read books i wanted to
watch tv but she made me read books
and as i read about doctors and
scientists
and historians and entrepreneurs
i begin to realize that the person who
has the most to do what happens to you
in life
is you it's not somebody else
and you know somebody else cannot
stop you and there was plenty of
prejudice
in those days you know they talk about
racism now
racism now that is a joke you know come
compared to what i grew up with that is
a
joke and and guess what everything won't
be racism after the election
that's kind of interesting isn't it but
um
you know i realized that i could do
anything i wanted in this country
it was up to me i just had the study i
had to work hard i had to have goals
i didn't expect anybody to give me
anything
and also as i talked to
the president wasn't president then i
realized that he also grasped a very
important principle and that is a rising
tide lifts
all boats and that's why he doesn't
engage in a lot of identity politics he
tries to do things that
raises the tide for everybody and what
has that done in the african-american
community
poverty rate down wages up
more people working unemployment at the
lowest levels by the end of
q4 2019 home ownership
going up it's at its highest rate since
2008 right now
the wealth gap decreasing on and on it
goes
you see what we need to do is look at
what he does
it's much more important than what
anybody says or what they
say he says or what they say he means
when he says
and also we must grasp our history the
history in the african-american
community is something to be proud of
the way that
our faith and our family got us through
slavery
and it got us through the periods after
slavery and
incredible segregation and racism
and those entities that are attacking
the nuclear family
and attacking our faith are not our
enemies no matter who they hide behind
no matter what celebrity
or sports star they they stand behind
they are not
the friends of this community and we
need to make sure that we know that
and we're at a when it comes to people
trying to destroy history
something that we all need to understand
your history is what gives you your
identity
your identity is what gives you your
beliefs and if you allow that to be
destroyed
you become easy prey for anybody who
comes along and that's exactly what's
happening right
now so
and be wary of those people who accuse
you and accuse us of exactly what
they're doing that's how you can tell
what they're doing whatever they accuse
you of that's what they're doing
and you know this election is not about
democrats
and republicans this is about people who
believe in
our system and people who want to
fundamentally change us
into something else
killing destroying intimidating people
those are not godly principles and we
should never invite people into our
community no matter
what has happened who throw bombs and
loot and destroy people's livelihood and
we see people welcoming them those
people ought to be shunned
kick them out of your neighborhood don't
let them destroy everything and then go
back to their lives of luxury what a
bunch of crap
you know and
and instead we need to be concentrating
on educating people
and on building our communities and
that's what president trump
is doing building our communities all
you have to do is look
all you have to do is open your eyes and
see what is happening the best things
that have
happened in a very long time in this
country
action speak louder than words
and partnering with somebody who also
believes in god and believes
in godly principles he believes in the
principles
of loving your neighbor of caring about
the poor of living
values and principles god bless
this country and god bless our president
thank you
[Applause]
good afternoon it's a pleasure to be
here with so many georgians and people
who are free-minded and know that
liberty still reigns in this country
today you know today kind of reminded me
of being in my home church
my african-american church in lawton you
know we've got people here who are
god-fearing we even got dr alvita king
who's liable to break out in song
in any minute we know she will but the
reason it reminds me of church is
because
about this time in my african-american
church that i grew up in
we'd always have politicians start
streaming anybody know what i'm talking
about
they started coming in promising you the
world and promising if you just keep
doing what you've always done
things are going to get better well
donald j trump
is different he is making a difference
in the lives of african americans
each and every day and he's doing it
with policies that
encourage in growth wealth and
investment because that's what this
country needs and that's what our
community needs
you know when i think about the
opportunities that exist for the people
of
america it is important to me that we
remember that they were founded on godly
principles
and i appreciate the fact that this is
the most significant election election
in our history and when we think about
the opportunities that are going to
exist for our kids and grandkids
it's not going to be because of a big
government socialist program
that's being pushed by biden and harris
it's going to be because of a president
who stands for liberty and justice for
all
so my message i know we're short on time
and you've heard a lot of speeches
every one of you today if you're
african-american
and you are a republican you know what
it means to be injured you know what it
means to stand up for what you believe
you know what it means
to have an aunt or a special cousin who
thinks less of you because of who you're
voting for but i want to tell you
don't give up because each one of you
stands in the shoes of harriet tubman
today
and miss tubman said it best she said
that i could have freed a thousand more
if they only knew they were slaves
[Applause]
and today
and i have one word and that is to our
president mr president
it is an honor for all of us to be here
and to welcome you to georgia
and to say that you have been a friend
not just to america
but you have been a true friend to black
america and we look forward to hearing
about
your platinum plan for how we move this
country forward and how we move
african african-american forward thank
you
and
[Applause]
hello it's all a pleasure to be with you
and uh this is a great time i believe
that
in america because i believe this is
time for revival to come
i absolutely do so as a senior pastor as
a bishop
and as an attorney i have certain core
values that i personally have
as it relates to this time that we're in
and i realized that i have to make my
decisions based on those values
one of those values is very very
important being a member literally
of this city here for born and raised i
recognize that i have to look at the
life of those that are unborn
those in the womb how how we're going to
protect
those in the womb and i realized even
with black babies in the womb they've
been
unprotected and as a result of that
they've been a direct result
of genocide of eugenics as a result
and so if i have to determine who is
going to protect
babies in the world i have to support
and i have to endorse president donald j
trump
[Applause]
also as an
advocate of religious liberty i care
about religious liberty and religious
freedom
and i believe that the next civil rights
movement actually is going to be a fight
for religious freedom
i believe the only way that we're going
to be able to stand we have to be
religious freedom fighters ourselves
but if i want to protect our first
amendment rights of religious freedom
i have to support and endorse
president donald j trump
[Applause]
i also served as the president of prison
fellowship
under under colson i also was the
chairman of georgia state board of
parties in paroles
i was a commissioner for juvenile
justice i care about
criminal justice and prison reform i've
seen the eyes of those that are in
prison
that are there many times too long and
they're not there for rehabilitation
so if i want to see more executive and
bipartisan legislative laws
such as the first step act i have to
support
and endorse donald j trump as president
of the united states
[Applause]
i personally attended howard university
undergraduate school in law school
i love the existence of historically
black colleges and universities
and i want more opportunities for young
people to be able to be world
changers so with in order to have
billions of dollars that could come and
help those hbcus
i have to support and endorse
the relation of donald j trump
[Music]
and lastly if i want to continue to see
a drop
in unemployment and the rate of black
americans and to see
economic uh empowerment of the black
community
i have to support and endorse president
donald j trump as president of states
lastly if i want to see true change in
our nation
hope for our nation revival in our
nation
among black and whites together i have
to support and endorse
donald j trump
well i'm a preacher so
no i'm not gonna preach but if if we was
in a good church i'd say can i get
somebody to give to
the lord a good praise right now
and one of the things about that moment
is
we can do that here
without being criticized without being
looked at wrong we can say let's give
god some praise
[Applause]
well i am here i'm from youngstown ohio
i'm from a town that uh
i grew up i'm a son of a preacher my
mother was an accountant for the
local university i was fortunate enough
to go to university
because she worked for the university
and so my education was free thank the
lord
and i wasn't that uh i was very
fortunate to be able to have good grades
thank the lord and so i i am a child who
grew up in the steel mill era
and jobs left like crazy and i've
watched the city and declination
i've been fortunate enough to be all
around the world and to do many things
i've never met i've met many
politicians i've met many leaders i've
never met nobody like this guy
i think for number one it's because he's
not a politician
what i've learned over the past three to
four years is bureaucracy
isn't as strong as we thought it was
you can get things done in a short
period of time
you can make a difference you can keep
your word
and he gets attacked quite a bit and i
get it i understand
following behind the things he's
followed behind and just done
he says what he feels
we mistake that for racism but i met him
uh
bruce we were together and and i said
let me test this racism
i know i'm black
no no no no and i say that for a reason
i understand being pulled over by police
because my car is nice
i understand some of these woes i am not
a compromising black man
i will never compromise my blackness
i'm proud to be a black man
[Applause]
and i will fight for black people as
long as i can
here's the deal when i met him
he touched me with strong
you know i'm donald j trump
uh he wasn't timid then i stood by his
daughter ivanka and it was time to pray
and i say let me test it again we were
holding hands
she reached out for my hand and she said
let's pray
she was pregnant i'll never forget it
and she held my hand
i say a racist man's child would never
[Applause]
so i got several reasons why i'm going
to support him
and i'm ready to take whatever heat
because it can't be hot enough
because the furnace is in my favor
i believe in righteousness and justice
i don't believe for fighting for justice
alone there must be righteousness
and i don't believe in fighting for
righteousness alone there must be
justice
i believe in the economic ability of
this man to
accomplish economics for all people
but black people as well he's proven it
i believe that his record is proven and
if we compare it to 47 years
of nothingness i shouldn't say
nothingness i should say
destruction
and if i have to prove a history i have
three years of a history that says you
got
opportunity zones you have uh
education opportunities you have prison
reform
uh i believe in police being
uh reformed and not eliminated
i am somebody who believes this is our
time
and we must take advantage of this
moment so
why am i voting for him why am i
endorsing him because i believe
that he is going to keep his word god
bless you
[Applause]
glory to god
i'm bishop wellington boone and i fully
support
and expect donald j trump to be the next
president of the united states
i i know a little bit about his
background and they
he came his forefathers from the
hebrides islands
one of the greatest revivals we know in
history came from the hebrides islands
and so what they're noted for is
calvinism and calvinism
says that there is a manifest destiny
over your life and this man and his
forefathers have said
that he's a product of manifest destiny
that god determined before the
foundation of the world
that he would become the president of
the united states
now i can clearly say say this to you
because this is important to understand
that by the fact that he is by his
fruits which you have all evidenced by
the things you are saying
you'll know them by their fruits the
priorities of scripture he has made
here as the president of the united
states remember it says that promotion
comes not from the east nor the west but
the south god lifts one up and takes
another down
god made this man president
and then by the fact
that he's targeted the inner cities and
all of your evidence that he's doing a
great job in reaching the inner cities
it shows the favor of god is on the
black community
the bible says not many wives are called
not many noble are called
but i've called the base thing to the
world to confound the wise
you are a prophetic sign that revival is
coming to black america
and god is using this man to do it
so we're joining with him because a
revival is coming
and let every man be a liar but let the
word of god
be true as we re-elect this man to be
president
it is a visible manifestation
that the revival is already here come on
let's read that
continue to do a great job mr president
it's your day god bless you
the good book says a nation divided
cannot stand
yet korea politicians relentlessly
divide this nation
the extreme left has been wasting
america's time with vile hoaxes and
delusional
witch hunts allowing lawlessness
refusing to condemn violence against our
fellow citizens
the democrat party has joined forces
with flag burners
anarchists korea politicians using their
positions to aid our enemies
at the expense of our allies for years
you had a president who
apologized for america now you have a
president who is standing up for america
instead of endless war we are forging
peace in the middle east
president trump supports our allies and
takes decisive action against those that
harm america
african-american poverty has declined
to the lowest rate ever recorded
president trump engineered the highest
ever employment for the black community
by generating the most robust
and inclusive economic growth in history
biden stated that if elected charter
schools are gone
access to education is a civil right
a nation divided cannot stand i have
done more in three years for the black
community than joe biden has done in 47
years
if you have a problem figuring out
whether you're for me or trump
and you ain't black to say i'm not black
if i don't vote a certain way come on
man
we don't have to be told how to vote we
can see who's real
instead of letting washington change us
we are changing
washington my president
your president our president
donald trump
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
hey oh god is good
[Applause]
now don't get me wrong this matches the
suit
you know i was born about two and a half
hours from here
knowing that i was colored i went to
college about an
hour and a half from here knowing that i
was black
i have a home here in atlanta knowing
that i'm african-american
but time has changed and now i'm proud
to be an american
[Music]
[Applause]
i played football in the 80s
in new york city and i met a young man
that i thought was very brass but uh
i learned that he loved his family he
loved this country
and he loved people so i remember
telling a reporter
from the new york new york times that
this guy
could be president of the united states
in 1985
because he loved america but i guarantee
you can't find that in the archives
today but i've always known that uh
he's different because he became the
45th president of the united states of
america
and i also get upset because he don't
get the credit he deserved for all the
things that he's done
in the african-american community like
the historical black colleges that
helped to build
great black leaders in the world today
and and also the prison reform that
benefit
most of the african-american so i get
upset about that
but you know his administration and
himself worked extremely hard
to do many things for americans not just
african-americans and you know i
said once when you give a man a job
you're giving self-worth and do you know
this president in three and a half years
put one million african-americans to
work
[Applause]
in eight years the obama biden
put 140 000 people to work
you know i've always said i will stand
shoulder to shoulder with this man
because he keeps god in the house
and all us americans
have received so many touchdown passes
from this man
that i want to say it is time for us to
recognize
our quarterback
so it's my honor and pleasure
to introduce my friend the president of
the united states of america
the fortified president donald j
[Music]
[Applause]
trump
[Music]
cause today ain't no doubt i love this
land
god bless the usa
thank you very much and thank you to
herschel
i don't know about herschel
i don't know i don't know i don't know
about hershey
i'd watch him in college i'd watch him
carry that ball but you know i think
he'd do just as well as a
senator or a governor
we're gonna have to start talking to him
about that he's a fantastic person
great man i'm honored to be back in the
heart of georgia with the truly
incredible
organization black voices for trump and
we appreciate it
in 39 days we're going to win four more
years in the white house
and we will do it with a record number
of votes from the
black community
that's all happening that's all
happening we're getting a lot of see the
people back there they're saying what's
going on over here
they're not happy about it but that's
okay our movement is welcoming
millions of black americans back to the
republican party the party of frederick
douglass
and abraham lincoln
when i ran for president four years ago
i looked at the dismal and shameful
record of the democrat party
and ask black americans what the hell do
you have to lose
right and they all said you shouldn't
use the word hell but i said it's just
it's more descriptive does it work as
well without it
today i want to share what you have to
gain
from voting republican on november 3rd
will be the biggest
election of our lives for decades
democrat politicians like joe biden
have taken black voters for granted
they made you big promises before every
election
and then the moment they got to
washington they abandoned you
and they sold you out the democrat party
used you
and they lied to you every single time
you know it better than anybody else
knows
the democrats will always take back
the vote what they want to do is they'll
take that vote back
they want to take the black voter for
granted and they have taken the black
voter for granted
and it's not fair it's not right and
it's not going to happen
because we're going to have such a
victory like you've never had before
in 2016. thank you
thank in 2016 i made you a solemn pledge
that whether you voted for me or not i
would be your greatest champion
since that time i've delivered even more
than
i promised it's one of those things few
politicians do that but i believe we
have
before the china virus we built the
greatest economy
for african americans in the history
of our country and we are doing it again
in the first three years we achieved the
lowest black unemployment rate
in history the black youth unemployment
rate
reached an all-time low
we achieved the largest job gains for
african americans on record
black americans saw the largest increase
in home
ownership the poverty rate for
african americans reached the lowest
level ever recorded
and last year 811 000
african americans were lifted out of
poverty the most
in over 51 years
in my first three years we lifted 6.6
million people out of poverty the
largest poverty reduction
of any president in the history of our
country
[Applause]
i did more for the black community
in 47 months i saw they used that line
so i don't want to
ruin it by saying it a second time it
was in the video but i will say it again
then joe biden did in 47 years
and i'm here today to announce a brand
new plan to deliver more opportunity
more security more fairness and more
prosperity
to black communities we call it the
platinum plan
platinum and that's a contract
with black americans and it's going to
be something that people talk about for
a long time to come
if you vote republican over the next
four years we will create three million
new jobs
for the black community
open 500 000 new black-owned businesses
increase access to capital in black
communities by
500 billion dollars
and this includes investing in community
development financial institutions and
minority
depository institutions
build up peaceful and safer urban
neighborhoods with the highest standards
of and you know this of policing we want
the highest standards
we have to have highest standards of
policing
bring even greater fairness to the
justice system we did criminal justice
reform we remember
that even greater we will create a
national
clemency project to write wrongful
prosecutions and to pardon individuals
who have reformed their life you saw
alice right
we love alice she had another 24 years
to go can you believe it
she served 22 years she had another 24
years to go
it was ridiculous
and she is a great woman create a ladder
of opportunity for
african-american children by delivering
school choice
to every parent in america so important
[Applause]
give black churches the ability to
compete for federal resources for their
communities bring better
and tailored health care to address the
historic disparities that we've had for
so many years you know that
this includes investing in treatments
for kidney disease diabetes high blood
pressure
sickle cell disease and maternal
mortality advance home ownership and
wealth building in the black
community bring more manufacturing back
to the usa which we're doing anyway
and back to the inner cities which have
been largely forgotten
although not so much in the last three
years when you get right down to it
thank you and democrat policies that
import low-wage foreign workers from
overseas to replace
black workers in our inner cities
joe biden cares more about the citizens
of foreign countries than he does about
black americans living in our own
country
i will always put americans first and
that includes
very very importantly black americans
[Applause]
and there's much more in our plan which
we're releasing today so we'll get
everyone a copy and it's actually been
very well received
and we appreciate that the platinum plan
is a bold vision that we can
and really will achieve over the next
four years and we'll be able to do it
if not sooner unlike my opponent i'm not
a career politician thank goodness
i get results and i keep my promise and
you you've seen that
you've seen that together we will not
only build up america's black
communities
we'll help with your vote with the
platinum plan we'll lift up
all forgotten communities and we'll
strengthen our entire nation
and we are going to have an incredible
four years but more importantly we're
going to have an incredible 40 years
we're going to have many many great
years
because we're setting a foundation for
the future
[Applause]
so when i'm not here you're going to be
here forever especially look at these
young people over here you're going to
really be there for a long time but
we want this for long term this year the
republican party has 26
black republicans running for congress
where are they are they here are they
here a lot of them are here right
whoa that's a good looking group of
people
and they're and they're doing and you're
doing well
just about in every instance well we're
going to help you to do even better
we'll be we'll be helping you you watch
and we're thrilled to be joined today by
eight of them
raise your hand where which are the
eight oh that's so
great yeah
they have what it takes that's great
that's fantastic great job one of them
i've endorsed very strongly i saw an ad
that i liked i said i thought it was
great
raise your hand please what a great um
they've they've been now endorsed i will
tell you
uh and congratulations by the way that's
going to be a fantastic
it's going to be a fantastic night
november 3rd now i don't know you know
with this ballot situation
it's uh you're not gonna you're not
gonna see it
november 3rd the democrats are playing
games you see that
you see they found ballots in a waste
paper basket
they found ballots dumped in a stream
take a look at iowa the primaries you
remember the primary
they went to iowa we love iowa but they
tried this ballot concept and they still
don't know who won
that was a long time ago that was in
their primary the first primary
and uh it's a very terrible thing that's
happening very very terrible thing but
you're going to be raising the hand if
not november 3rd hopefully shortly
thereafter
i know you're going to be raising your
hand with me we may end up in a dispute
for a long time because that's the way
they want it
but we're going to end up winning that's
for sure okay
when i give my state of the union
address next year i look forward to
welcoming a historic number of black
republican members of congress
and we're going to take back the house
[Applause]
you know we've already won some seats
back they don't like to talk about that
the fake news you'll find
out about the fact have you figured out
the fake news yet you're young
and handsome and beautiful have you
figured out the fake news yet
you you'll learn you'll learn you learn
to live with it you learn to do what you
have to do
but we are going to take back the house
i think we're only 17 short now we
picked up a couple
we just won a big one in los angeles we
haven't won in 22 years
california won a big one in wisconsin it
was a great one we won some really good
ones so
uh we're inching up and you watch what's
going to happen it's going to be a very
big night for the house
it's going to be a really retired pelosi
that's out of bed
that's going to be great congratulations
all that's a
that's already a great achievement it
really is it's all ready
but together we'll fulfill our contract
with black america and we'll pass
the platinum plan into law and we'll do
it quickly and easily
we're also joined by a great friend of
mine dr ben carson where's ben
ben i love ben special man
he's doing a great job too he's been my
friend from the beginning
can i tell the one story ben he came up
to me during he was campaigning he was
the toughest one i mean to tell you what
we had some really tough ones you know a
lot of them like to try and say they
were tough but they weren't like kasich
like casey he only had one thing he
wouldn't leave the race
he'd get he'd get minus one he's going
on to the next one
this guy did great he was incredible and
he came up to me during the race and he
was doing well
he said you know that you're going to
win don't you i said
excuse me he said you know you're going
to win he was doing great
and he was uh really like in second
and third and fourth and back to second
i mean he was right up there he was
great
i learned i said we gotta get this guy
out of here
but he came up to me he did and he said
you're going to win and i'll let him
tell you the rest of the story if you'd
like to do it sometime but
he gave a very specific reason and i
will never forget what he said but he
said you know you're going to win don't
you
and i just thought it was really nice
and you know what i'm talking about ben
so ben carson what a job he's done too
respected by everybody
thank you
and a man who ran in the primary who
i got a call from another great man
david perdue he said could you do us a
favor
there's a guy named brian kemp
and he's running in a tough primary
you've got a tough opponent
and do you think you could maybe endorse
him i love david perdue i said
i said who is he i don't know okay and
he said well he's been for you i said
well i've heard that before i better be
careful
and we did a little where's brian
where's brian right over here brian
we did a little research we did a little
research and he has he was
for me all the way and i said that's
good you know the worst thing is when
you're endorsing people that say bad
things right he only said good
and i got to know him and i got to know
his wife marty and i i said absolutely
and we endorse him and he won that
primary so easily
he won so easily and they're still
trying to figure out what happened
in the race i've been watching
you know what it wasn't that close he
won by like a lot
actually you know he didn't win by 15
votes he won by
a lot how many votes was that that was a
lot
well we won't go on a landslide but it
wasn't very close you know
how many votes was that brian it was a
lot
51 to me you know what that is that's
yankee stadium for a world series
oh you know people would say oh that was
tight i don't think
like they heard i heard i won michigan
by 12 000. i said that's an
almost full madison square garden you
know not quite full but that's
yankee stadium for the world series i
think that's a lot we look at it
differently
uh but i do want to introduce also david
perdue who was
uh he is really an incredible guy he
loves everybody in this room where's
david david please stand up
is that right did you make that call
[Applause]
you made that call he made that call and
that was a good call
because your governor's doing a great
job and david's doing a great job and i
hope you can
support david and brian and all of them
they're incredible people
thank you thank you thank you david for
everything
thanks also to oklahoma's first black
speaker of the house t.w shannon
[Applause]
where's cw i like that
i want to do that i want to do that
thank you two great reputation thank you
very much and
a friend of mine who uh my
children you know they'll always be
children they may be a little older than
children but they're always my children
they love her
lynn patton lynn thank you thank you
thank you thank you
and if you're a uh ufc fan anybody like
ufc
it's uh i'll tell you what that's right
usman he goes usman
he's uh i know who he is he's tough
that's who he is
kamuro usman where is uh where is our
champ come on champ get up
man oh man oh man
what a fighter you are i don't want to
mess with him i may weigh a couple of
pounds more do you think i could take
you to fight you up i don't think so
he goes no i think you're right yeah but
i watched a fight you had
a couple of months ago unbelievable uh
and talent
but right up here too you know it's a
combination the muscles are important
but uh you gotta have the other
you gotta have you know he actually
looks very good in the suit but he's one
of the few people who look better
without a suit
there aren't too many of us hey there
aren't too many of us that can say that
right
right men the men of this audience huh
but i just uh i just want to thank you
champion good luck i'll be watching you
have a big fight coming up and i'll be
watching and uh
it's a great group of people great group
of champions thank you very much
thank you
another great fighter
ali abdelaziz who is uh
tough where is he there he is oh you're
tough
you're so tough the two of you guys i'd
like to see you both fight but there's a
little weight difference i guess right
you probably think you could take him
right but what is the difference in
weight
what is it 20 10
i know i know i know what is it though
because
and how were you a fighter at one time
and how good you you
pretty good not good as nobody else is
either so you know
that's easy yeah you were a good fighter
uh also atlanta's top
hip-hop producer polo
where is he where is he de don
you know don king used to call me the
don
right he used to he still does actually
but you didn't get it from don king i
know that right nice to see you
great to have you great to have you
thank you very much do we have another
ufc fighter here because i had heard yes
uh because i know we had somebody else
go i just don't want to skip in case we
do i have a lot of respect for them
anybody gets in a ring and does that and
comes out winning
uh to me i have a lot of respect and
when you become the champ
i want to tell you it's uh that's a hell
of a that's a hell of a thing that's
what you live for the belt right
the money or the belt you know what if
you get the belt the money
comes right so great great going chip
fantastic
over the last 50 years black americans
have mostly
voted democrat but every day more black
americans are deciding that the
old way is not working five decades of
evidence proved that democrat
politicians do not care about the black
community
they only care about power for
themselves whatever that means
my opponent is offering black americans
nothing but the same
old tired empty slogans
by the way he uh he's staying in again
today
the guy hey champ if i lose to a guy
that
that's like you losing losing to a
fighter that you know hasn't worked out
in the last six months
this guy never goes out it's terrible
huh
well you better make sure i when i'm
going to be very embarrassed i lost to a
guy
i lost to a guy that didn't campaign you
know why he's not campaigning i guess
it's an energy factor so what the hell
is going on
if i lose to a man that doesn't campaign
no he's
announced every day he announced we're
going to stay in today
i don't know hey i can't tell you
but the democrats are angry at them they
say you can't do that you know i just
left florida
and from here i'm going to washington
then i'm going to virginia then i'm
going to someplace else and someplace
else
by the way am i you know i see kelly and
i see collins back there will you please
stand up
okay please
you know
those are two champions so you know they
had their names in there but they took
them out you know why because they
probably want to
not mention them together they're going
to end up liking each other you watch
and they're two great people i'm not
going to skip them over
they thought it would be diplomatic
that's not diplomatic that's stupid
right but i stand here to offer
solutions i want to congratulate you
both
really fighting a good fight i want to
say that both of you doug
kelly really great it's uh i mean well i
sort of like it you know why
they're going to be in the fighting
fighting fighting don't anybody get out
you're going to get any girls and
everybody's going to come with them
and the only thing i know for sure
they're all going to vote for me both
so brian don't let them get out don't
let anybody get out let them
that's going to be a but everyone's
going for both of them
huh okay it's going to be hey we don't
have long to go either we don't have
long to go
november 3rd i've spent the last four
years
reversing the horrible damage joe biden
inflicted on the black community over 47
years 47 years he always says oh i
should have done this i said you've been
there for 47 years you know
it's always great when they tell you
what you should be doing and they
haven't done it themselves
and you know it's not like it was 25
years ago that he left he
was there three and a half years ago
right so
you know it's one of those things no one
in washington politics today
has done more to hurt black americans
and joe biden
it's strange for half a century joe's
personally advocated or enacted
virtually every policy that has caused
pain and suffering in the black
community you know that joe biden
shipped
millions of your best jobs overseas
hollowed out
the black middle class and with open
borders trapped children
in failing government schools sent young
men to fight
in endless wars they just never end
they're coming back home you see that
they're coming back home
many are already back while our inner
cities crumbled at home
and made cities less safe and less
secure
joe biden should not be demanding your
support
he should be begging for your
forgiveness he really should be
my opponent drafted the 1994 disaster
the 1994 crime bill which caused unfair
sentencing disparities
that devastated black families and i
mean just devas
i have heard more about the 1994
and when we did criminal justice reform
it was largely about
erasing that terrible act
i was a that was his that was his deal i
roll back
the unfair provisions of the 1994 biden
crime bill
and i signed it into groundbreaking
criminal justice reform which people are
so happy about
even my enemies are saying thank you for
that
today we're glad to be joined by the
first person to be released under the
first step back who i was honored to
have as my guest at the
state of the union a really wonderful
man matthew charles
[Music]
what a good man what a smile i looked at
that smile from the podium downstairs i
was surrounded by all those killer
politicians
and i looked at matthew who's the nicest
looking guy in the house
thank you matthew you're doing well
matthew right that's great man
you deserve what you got we deserve it
biden supported the twin disasters of
nafta and
china's entry into the world trade
organization which eliminated one in
four manufacturing jobs
held by black americans you know that
joe biden's globalist agenda closed down
factories in baltimore and sent them
just see what happened all these
factories all these jobs
all these factories sent them to beijing
he shuddered the plants in michigan and
he sent them to mexico
i replaced nafta one of the worst trade
deals one of the worst stupidest deals
i've ever seen in my life
with the new u.s mexico canada agreement
creating hundreds of thousands of new
jobs
that was one they said could not be done
david right they said it couldn't be
done
david perdue they said that one couldn't
be done right david
and we got it done in pretty quick time
too
to revitalize neglected communities we
created nearly
9 000 opportunity zones with
tim scott south carolina you know tim
scott
tim scott is great senator tim scott
from south carolina came to my office
came to the oval office and he had this
idea and i said that sounds good
and we got it done and people were
surprised that we could even get it done
and it has turned out to be incredible
75 billion dollars
of investment are poured into these
neighborhoods which will create an
estimated 500
000 jobs and lift 1 million americans
out of poverty
when the china virus struck we raced to
ensure that
black americans had the medical care and
the financial support that they needed
through the paycheck protection program
which was a big deal we helped save over
200 000 black
owned small businesses a lot of
a lot of small businesses it's uh it's
incredible
the uh the black community has
tremendous talent in terms of those
businesses and small businesses we saved
at least 200
000 of them as we continue to battle the
virus my administration is sheltering
those at highest risk while rapidly
developing treatments and the vaccine is
coming very quickly i see where
a couple of the democrats don't want to
have the vaccine because they say well
we don't want it because we think trump
is pushing it too fast well that's the
reason we're going to have it
this would have taken this would have
taken years to
to get we're years ahead of schedule and
uh
this would have been two three years by
democrats and uh
but now they're things they're very
concerned because they're afraid it's
happening too fast and that means we're
going to get credit
i don't want credit we want to save
lives
[Applause]
we will crush the virus our opponents
will crush the
black middle class that's what they've
been doing and they've been doing it
for a long time for too long they will
deliver a crippling shutdown and a
very steep depression if he gets elected
this guy
okay you will have the greatest
depression
that this country has ever seen and that
includes a pretty big one in 1929 hello
how are you
great i love her dress
that's great thank you for being here i
didn't know you're going to be here
thank you very much
nearly 1.3 million african-americans
have gotten jobs in the last four months
alone
and next year we will be i think it'll
be the greatest year and
economically the greatest year in the
history of our country and that's good
for everybody
that's good for everybody right
especially for these
young geniuses these young political
geniuses that are coming along
but i think we're going to have the
greatest year in the history of our
country economically and i think our
third quarter which happens to be it's
going to be announced two days before
you know the numbers come out two days
before the election
right at the beginning of november and
uh i mean i'll say it now
these people all those people up there
they'll hold me to it they won't give me
credit if i was right but if i was wrong
it'll be headlines we have breaking as
trump said wrong
but i think we're going to have a
tremendous third quarter
after years of rebuilding other
countries we're finally rebuilding
our country
the path to the american dream has
always been education
republicans believe that school choice
is the civil rights issue of all time
[Music]
and joe biden isn't allowed to go there
because of the radical left he's
controlled by the radical left totally
he's exhausted but biden's promised a
ban
on charter schools and to oppose school
choice
joe biden is willing to spend billions
and billions upon
resettling refugees from all around the
world
but he won't spend one penny providing
school choice to black children in
america
which is interesting during their first
year in office
president obama and vp biden
cut funding for historically black
colleges
and universities i've increased
hbcu funding and i made it from
[Applause]
you know just a quick story so so what
was happening is that
be there the first year i saw these
probably 42 people
came up and they were the heads of
individual
colleges historically black colleges
universities
and they were the heads of not seeing
them i said oh i was hello
they were nice people we took a picture
in the white house we do that you know a
lot of presidents don't believe anyone
should ever enter the oval office but
then with me i say come on in
but we took a picture then the next year
they were there again i said right
we know the story my friend we know the
story they were there and i said oh what
are you doing back here
they said we're here because uh we need
money again i said what do you mean
again
and i forgot about it you know i said
all right well what is
and they got it and then uh the third
year
david they came in again right and i
said what is this
what are you guys here for i mean you're
great people but why
well we don't have any funding they
don't have permanent funding
so they could be shut out if they had
the wrong president you know honestly
you could have the wrong president and
you wouldn't get 10 cents they wouldn't
give you anything
and and i said that's terrible so you
come up here every
do you like doing it no and the one
gentleman looked at me said we feel like
beggars that was a hell of a statement
you know i said
i understand that and i said we can't
let this happen
so we worked on it david perdue
all of us worked on it kelly worked on
it we all worked on it
and and frankly
and i have to say uh you know it had to
go through
the house and where's doug doug worked
on it right you remember that
that was a hard thing it wasn't easy
there were people that didn't want to do
it
and we got it passed we got more money
than they asked for i said you're going
to need
more i'm in the real estate business i
said you always need more
whatever you think you need you need
more but we got more money than they
asked for and we got it for a period of
10 years right
so i said the only bad we signed it
together about 42 people
we signed it together i said the only
bad thing is that i like you people i
won't see you anymore
i won't see you for another 10 years
let's see will we be president in 10
years oliver
only if we had a couple of terms and oh
this now we have a story there's your
breaking news
i told you he's a dictator we've been
he will not give up power under no
circumstances will he give up power
he intends to serve at least two more
terms
[Music]
oh that's a big thing you know you can't
joke because if you joke
they take it away you know a lot of
times with a little sarcasm
and you joke but you're being serious
and then you start laughing afterwards
but they always cut it before the laugh
they cut it so that they think he's
serious he wants
wants 12 more years they start shouting
now 12 more years
ah thank you earlier this year biden
said that
if you don't vote for him then you ain't
black you know that
and this was very uh outrageous this was
offensive in fact
he was very derisive of the black
americans when he very negatively
compared them to another group of
americans who was very terrible and he
did it
biden believes that all black americans
have to
think the same way that's what it was
all about
today's democrat party is run but he
doesn't know
black americans like i do
[Applause]
today's democrat party is run by out of
touch
liberal hypocrites who stereotype you
disrespect
you and sell you out they're only good
for your six-month period six months
before the election
and then they're very nice and they want
your vote and then they as you say i
like that better than what i'm saying
they forget all about you
they're gone they're gone biden wants to
lecture the country about racial justice
when he
spent his career hurting black americans
hurting hispanic americans and forging
alliances
with pro-segregate democrat
senators you know that racial justice
begins with
joe biden's retirement from public life
so today i'm urging black americans to
walk away from the corrupt hateful
divisive
and very extreme and they are going
crazy democrat party
on no issue has the democrat party more
totally failed the black community than
public safety
democrats have run america's inner
cities at every level of government
for 100 years and even more last year
19 of the top 20 most dangerous cities
in america when run by democrats the
murder rate
is higher in baltimore than in
afghanistan el salvador
or honduras right it's higher
instead of fighting for public safety
for these communities
the democrats are attacking our police
and empowering far-left rioters looters
and anarchists you know they are
anarchists
the democrat party's war on cops
has caused black-owned businesses to be
burned and
black homes and churches to be totally
destroyed
most tragically of all so many innocent
black lives have been cruelly taken from
us
people are dying by the thousands and
black on black crime
and i wanted to stop and people aren't
talking about it
they're not talking about it
they're not talking about it in chicago
as an example
there are weekends when 60 70 or more
people are
shot this is shot and many die
how can we allow this to go on how can
we allow this to happen
but they're all democrat-run cities
every year thousands of
african-americans are murdered as a
result of violent crime and
again in these democrat run
monstrosities the way they run them it's
worse
it's worse than afghanistan it's worse
than we're at war we go to war zones and
we don't lose this many people in war
zones
democrats ignore these american victims
and i won't and you know we have to be
asked to come in we have to be
asked to come in by law they have to say
please come in
and wherever we've gone in minneapolis
we went in we solved the problem they
should have called us two weeks earlier
they would have had a city left okay
but seattle they knew we were coming in
i said we're going in
we don't care we're going in the night
before we went in they left
that was the end of that and others
i mean look at look at portland i mean
how bad is portland
how bad is portland and we could solve
that one in about a half an hour
a bunch of young anarchists they live
with their parents
in a basement also they live in a bank
and i'll always support the heroes of
law enforcement we have to
including
[Applause]
including over 50 000 incredible black
police officers who risk their lives
every day to keep us all safe
you know they protect people that
they've never met before
and it's very dangerous it's they're
amazing
those pushing to defund the police are
hurting black communities the most
and as i've always said when there is
police misconduct
the justice system must hold wrongdoers
fully
responsible and accountable and they
will
and they will do that politicians
supporting
mob violence are not allies of the black
community they're causing
extraordinary damage grief hardship
in recent months our nation has grieved
for the tragic deaths
of brianna taylor george floyd and ahmad
aubry our hearts break for their
families and for all families who have
lost a loved one especially if you look
at this way
so so senseless but we can never allow
marlborough to have safety to have
prosperity
to have everything that you want to have
we must always ensure the rule of law
as you know we have to
many of those who are spreading violence
in our cities
are supporters of an organization
called black lives matter or blm
it's really it's really hurting the
black community it's hurting the black
women
this is an unusual name for an
organization whose
ideology and tactics are right now
destroying many black lives
and whose first phrase was you remember
this
pigs in a blanket fry them like bacon
referring to our police that's referring
to our police
the stated goal of blm organization
people is to achieve the destruction of
the nuclear family
abolish the police abolish prisons
abolish border security abolish
capitalism and abolish
school choice that's what their stated
goals are
this is not the agenda of the black
community this is the agenda
of an extreme socialist or worse
you know what the other word is yeah
marxist communist
communism but this is the extreme
socialist
left but beyond that in my opinion
that's why the founders of the
organization call themselves
trained marxists and yet we have major
corporations
out of weakness or fear or whatever
reason donating
hundreds of millions of dollars to them
these are fools
these are fools
[Applause]
the big progressive corporations
donating to blm
should instead be spending their money
helping black families rebuild
from the left ring i mean from these
horrible left-wing riots
wealthy liberal hypocrites want to
defund the police in our inner cities
while
living behind walled compounds
they're wall compounds it's uh you got
to see the way some of these people live
they live pretty well
you know the funny thing is that if
anything ever happened they'd be the
first to go you know that right
let's go get these people they're fools
they want to get rid of school choice
for black children while sending
their own children to the best private
schools in the land
they want to open borders and that's
what they want they want open borders
for you but security for themselves
they want top security but let's open up
the borders let's let everybody pour
into our country so that
you won't have jobs left you won't have
anything left you won't have and it's a
tremendous public health
crisis you know we built now over 330
miles of wall
and it will be finished
soon and our numbers on the border are
now the best they've been in
decades and it's incredible what's
happened the wall has been incredible
330 miles david that's pretty good a
long way considering we had a party that
didn't want to
let us build the world you know they
wanted the wall 10 years ago they really
wanted the wall
and as soon as i wanted it they didn't
want it and i made i
say this i said it last night we had a
tremendous rally last night with
probably 35 000 people i said it last
night
i said i said i made a mistake i should
have said
we will not build a wall and we would
and we would have had funding in about
15 minutes instead i had a
i had to win six different lawsuits this
was not ethan
crazy nancy she's a she's crazy
and you know do you notice how quiet it
is now now it's 330 miles it'll be built
first
it'll be completed we're doing 10 miles
a day on average
think of this i don't hear any more
about the wall
they don't want to talk they don't want
to talk about the wall anymore but the
numbers are great republicans will
always
uphold equal justice under the law we
will defend the civil rights of every
single american
and we will defend our god-given
freedoms including religious liberty
[Applause]
and the second amendment by the way
second amendment after you save our
second amendment i'm the only thing
standing between
between you and me
and second amendment i'm standing right
now
we're not gonna be losing our second
amendment
they're going to get rid of it you know
they put in charge beetho
beethoven beethoven
that's a spanish name he wanted to be he
needed the spanish vote right he needed
he said i want spanish
i said what about hispanic he said i
don't know about that he knows less
about it than
perhaps i do but beto remember he had a
cover in a
terrible magazine and they said he said
that i was born to run for president
he was hot then even though he just lost
a race to texas
he was hot you know and he said i was
born to run for president
i was but anybody that says that is a
sure loser
can you imagine if i said that i said i
was born to run for president you said
this guy's whacked out this guy
it's not an easy deal going on over here
i'll tell you i had a very nice life
before you know that you sort of read
about my life you knew a lot about my
life i had a great life
what the hell did i do this for david
what did i do this for
david perdue
no i enjoy it you know why i enjoy it i
love it
oh by the way did you see they just got
the fbi did you see the
the text messages oh it's brutal
one of the guys said listen this is
really illegal i want insurance
they bought insurance for these people
because they thought they're going to be
locked up
we got it now they're going crazy this
is the hottest thing right now on the
internet all over the place
ah boy oh boy we've they've been looking
at me
so essentially then it was the exact
opposite
okay and you see biden's son he got
three and a half hunter where's hunter
remember
[Applause]
where's hunter you know what i do i call
him where's hunter that's his name
where's hudson
we made a t-shirt i was making a speech
i said where's hunter where is i'm
looking at this
i was kidding i said where's hunter the
next day was the biggest selling t-shirt
in the history of
where's out there no hunter got a check
from the wife of the mayor of
moscow for three and a half million
would anybody accept whatever he was
supposed to do for three and a half
million
there's no job that i can think of three
and a half million now before
biden became vice president right he got
nothing
he had no money no nothing got thrown
out of the military
he got thrown out he had no job now he's
getting checks for three and a half
million
from the mayor the ex-mayor
very substantial person by the way of
moscow so we got it wrong
it wasn't trump i have nothing to do i
didn't have a phone call
now think of it let's call bob mueller
put him on the case
thank you thank you he said let's call
bob mueller i stole from him hey
i played your eyes from him like like
biden
that was very good he says let's call
bob mueller bob's a sharp guy let's
he'll get him
he'll figure it how about me three years
of investigation 48 million
they find nothing a friend of mine very
smart in new york said
very smart he said you must be the most
honest person in the world when 19
geniuses bad people but geniuses plus
unlimited law enforcement
49 fbi agents two and a half years
can't find anything you got to be the
cleanest person
in the world
that's but it turned out to be the
opposite story
it was them who was dealing with russia
david if you guys could start working on
that when you get back
doug please if you don't mind you were
so incredible to me
and if you don't mind think of it it was
the exact opposite doug we're trying to
he's trying to defend us please defend
the president well
it turned out to be the opposite they
were the ones that were dealing with
russia it was a disinformation campaign
kelly stop working on that with david
please okay i think monday morning would
be okay well we
we are appointing a supreme court
[Applause]
justice
[Music]
uh
now we are that's a big deal you know
the democrats
they don't think we should do it because
you know we have actually we have a lot
of time left you know it's really
january 20th we have a lot of time left
but they don't think we should do it
because it's
toward the end of the first we've got a
lot of time left
now put them in our shoes
do you think they'd say well i i you
know i think we should probably not do
this
what chance do we have of that david
zero would you say
no the only difference is they would
have gone even crazier they would have
gone totally
they would have been fighting let's get
it done immediately they would
they would be working over the weekend
no they're they're just they have been
not good to deal with
but you know what when we built this
great success
it started to all come together then we
got interrupted by
china what they did they should never
have done that they should remember this
we could never forget it
but it was starting to come together and
it will come together because we're
going to have an even greater success in
my opinion next year
well democrats have tried to silence
pastors
and we had some great pastors up here i
watched backstage
i watched those guys and i said i don't
want to follow them
i don't want to follow them i was
looking for somebody else to speak first
but uh they were great weren't they
really great
you know the truth i could say they love
you they love the country
they at least like me because you know
what if they didn't they couldn't do
what they just did they they did it
they did it from the heart didn't they
not really i watched that
i won't forget it either i'm never gonna
forget it i'm not forgetting i don't
i don't forget things thank you
[Applause]
i don't forget things where are the
pastors they got up where are they
where are they where are those guys man
oh man
[Applause]
i'll never follow you again
at least we had herschel in between
right
and herschel didn't like it either that
was really great thank you both thank
you all very much that was beautiful
that was from the heart and we
appreciate it we won't forget
we won't forget i will fiercely defend
the vital role of
black churches in america okay
joe biden and the democrats say that
black lives matter
but they do not protect the most
vulnerable black lives of all
unborn children they support the
unlimited abortion of black children
right up until the ninth month of
pregnancy
and if you look at this governor of
virginia beyond i had not heard that
but if you look at the governor of
virginia he said the baby is born and
then they start to talk
i said wait a minute that's not abortion
that's that's not abortion
you know that is no it's it's i call it
i call it execution
really you've seen that right i had not
heard that
you hear late term abortion you never
heard that but the governor of
virginia the one that thinks he's
michael jackson
the one whose wife stopped him whose
wife stopped him from trying to imitate
michael jackson moonwalker
and one thing we know he's not going to
be michael there's no
uh there's nobody there's nobody that
can moonwalk like michael she
he got very lucky that would have been
the end if he would have done that
but the democrats championed planned
parenthood an organization founded on
racism that continues to target the
black community
in the republican party we believe in
protecting all black lives
including the unborn we believe that
every child
of every race born and unborn is made in
the holy image of god
[Applause]
republicans believe that all human life
is sacred
at no time before has there been a
clearer choice between two parties two
visions two philosophies
two agendas for the future now you know
that there's never been a difference
like this
our opponents want our children to grow
up in a socialist nation
that will mean less opportunity less
prosperity
less safety and less hope for the future
the democrat party's message to your
children is that their path is doomed
and that their country
is evil my message every child in
america is the exact opposite
i want our children to know that they
are part of the most exciting and
incredible adventure in human history
no matter where your family comes from
no matter your background
in america anyone can rise democrats
divide our country by race
republicans unite americans through our
shared bonds of
citizenship you see it here this
glorious country is the shared heritage
of all americans
in every generation black patriots
poured out their blood
sweat heart and soul to defend american
liberty
and to realize our founding promise that
we are all made equal
by the hand of almighty god
african-american leaders lifted up the
conscience of our nation
to end slavery and segregation and
secure your civil rights black heroes
like
harriet tubman sojourner truth
booker t washington martin luther king
rosa parks and thurgood marshall helped
build the most just
noble free and exceptional nation on
earth
now with the help of a new generation of
black patriots
and there some of them are right now we
will reach new heights of glory and
greatness
we will revit and you know this we are
going to
revitalize our cities we are it's in the
process
we will bring more jobs and factories
back to our communities
we will give every single child a chance
to reach
their full god-given potential
we will build the most inclusive society
the most successful economy and the most
inspiring future the world has ever seen
and we will do it for citizens of every
background every race religion
color and creed together we made
unbelievable progress
and achieved once unimaginable
success nobody thought it was possible
and with your support
your vote and your voice the best
is yet to come
[Applause]
so this has been a great honor for me i
have a lot of friends in the audience
and i just want to thank you very much
god bless you
god bless america god bless you all
thank you
thank you very much thank you
[Music]
there's no need to feel down
cause you're in a new town
and i'm sure
[Music]
to enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
are you listening to
you me make real your dreams but you've
got to
know